all right well using all the skills that
you've learned throughout this course
it's time to make some final tweaks to
the hometown site to start off I want
you to update the sports score table go
ahead and put your favorite sports teams
in and make sure it's responsive I've
also added another column into the
sports score table just to make things a
little bit more difficult next up double
check your text is there any text that's
too long if so find a way to make it fit
a little bit more naturally this is also
a great place to add some minor
breakpoints at at least one or I'm sure
if you keep trying you could find a lot
more than just one to add Leslie try
replacing a few of the images with
responsive images if you haven't
completed the responsive images course
check out the responsive images section
of web fundamentals using the link in
the instructor notes and when you're
done make sure you share your project in
the forums that's the best way to get
feedback and make improvements